[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في دباسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى نبدا من هذه الصور التي
تاتينا من تل ابيب ومشهد الاحتجاج
المتصاعد ضد حكومه نتنياهو بعد تمرير
القراءه الاولى من التعديلات القضائيه اما
هذه الصور فتاتين مباشره من نيويورك وجلسه
في مجلس الامن بطلب روسيا تناقش قضيه
تفجير انبوبه الخاص بنقل الغاز
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
قمه قاده الناتو تختتم يومها الاول في
ليتوانيا انضمام اوكرانيا محور خلاف بين
كياف ودول في الحلف
يحيل العمليه الى استكمال الشروط واشنطن
تربطها بتحقيق اصلاحات عسكريه وسياسيه
يصف التاجيل بلعبه وفي حديث عن روسيا قاده
الناتو يصفونها كاكبر تهديد مباشر وموسكو
تقول انها ستراقب انشطه الحلف في السويد
وفنلندا
بالتزامن مع التلويحي بالانسحاب من عضويه
الايجاد الخارجيه السودانيه تقول انها
ستعتبر اي قوه افريقيه تنشر في البلاد
معتديه وتهاجم الرئيس الكيني والرئيس
وزراء اثيوبيا بعد حديثهما عن فراغ سياسي
وفرض حظر طيران والسفير الامريكي في
الخرطوم يقول ان الكلفه الانسانيه لحسم
الصراع عسكريا ستكون باهظه
احتجاجات التغييرات القضائيه تلاحق حكومه
نتنياهو غداه اقرار الكنيسه قراءه اولى
لمشروع قانون يقلص صلاحيات قضاه المحكمه
العليا الاحتجاجات تعود الى ذروتها مع
تاهب امني واسع لقمع المتظاهرين رؤساء
حكومه سابقون وقاده اجهزه امنيه يدعون الى
عصيان مدني والبيت الابيض يطالب حكومه
نتنياهو بالحفاظ على حق التظاهر
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا مشهد اقتحام قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منزل عائله سب لبن في القدس
المحتله حيث اعترضت العائله بذريعه وجود
قرار قضائي واستولى في المقابل مستوطنون
على المنزل وكانت العائله استاجرت البيت
في خمسينيات القرن الماضيه وخاضت معركه
قانونيه لسنوات لكن المحكمه العليا
الاسرائيليه قضت باخراج العائله رغم وجود
البند القانوني المعروف بالمستاجر محمي
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي
مقالات استلاء الى احتلال على منازل
العائلات المقدسيه مع عدم حمايتهم قضائيا
وجاءت النتائج كالتالي
42% توقعوا تصاعد التوتر في القدس بينما
قال خمسه في المئه ان ممارسه ضغوط دوليه
ستؤدي الى تق ليص عمليات الاستيلاء في حين
راى 53% ان عمليات الاستيلاء ستتواصل
بوتيره اكبر
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
يواصلوا قاده حلف الناتو قمتهم الهامه
التي تستمر يومين لمناقشه ملفات الدعم
لاوكرانيا والانفاق الدفاعي وقال الناتو
ان قاده الحلف الواحد وثلاثين يجتمعون في
لحظه حرجه للامن عبر المحيط الاطلسي وشهدت
قمه الناتو زخما جديدا بعد ان اعلنت انقره
موافقتها على البدء في اجراءات التصديق
على عضويه السويد في الحلفة كما صنف قاده
الناتوروسيا اكبر تهديدا لامن الحلفاء
لكنهم دعوا للابقاء على قنوات اتصال معها
لمنع التصعيد
لحظه حرجه هي حرجه للامن عبر الاطلسي
النيت نفسه هو من يقولها عن توقيت التئام
قمته هذه في ليتوانيا
من هنا يطلق الحلف اصلاحا يعزز خطط الدفاع
والردع وسياسه الانفاق الدفاعي
ويطلق معه رساله وحده صف الى روسيا
ورساله دعم عسكري قوي الى اوكرانيا
سريعا تقدمت برلين وباريس المتعهدين بدعم
اضافي لكيف كييف التي ستعرض عليها قمه
ايضا اجراءات الامنيه المؤقته وصفت
بالملموسه لكن ماذا عن مساله دخول النيتو
لن يخلو الامر من شروط لكنها لا تتعارض
واجراءات يعتزم الحلف اتخاذها ويرى انها
ستقرب اوكرانيا اليه
سنتخذ اليوم قرارات كبيره من اجل تعزيز
التحالف سنعزز دعمنا العسكريه والسياسيه
لاوكرانيا حيث نقربها من النيتو وسنتخذ
خطوات شجاعه لتعزيز قدرات الدفاع بما في
ذلك خطط جديده للدفاع عن منطقه اليورو
اطلس كما سنتفق على تعهدات طموحه من اجل
الاستثمار في الدفاع
واشنطن هي بين عواصم غربيه وازنه في
النيتو تصارح كييف بان مساله انضمامها
للحلف خلال الحرب غير مطروحه
الرئيس بعيده ادويه في حلف الناتو في حال
الحرب
ليست ممكنه ولكن يركز على دعم اوكرانيا في
حال الحرب من العدوان الروسي ونستمر في
ذلك
حلفاء اوكرانيا الغربيون يتفهمون على
الارجح استياء الرئيس الاوكراني من موقف
يصفه بالعبثي والمتردد
لن يتردد النيتو كثيرا كما يبدو مع مرشح
اخر للانضمام الى صفوفه على خطى فنلندا
امكن ذلك بعد دعم تركيا التحاق السويد
بالحلف وارسال المجر اشارات في ذلك
الاتجاه
يتناوب الحلفاء على وصف اللحظه بالتاريخيه
وبانها معززه لامن الحلف واوروبا في موسكو
تختلف بالطبع زاويه الرؤيه
يرى الكريملين ان دخول اوكرانيا المحتمل
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي سيشكل خطرا كبيرا
على الامن الاوروبي وان انضمام السويد الى
الحلف له تداعيات سلبيه على الامن الروسي
وسيتطلب ردا لا يكتفي الروس اذا وهم
يراقبون قمه النيتو من كثب بالتنبيه الى
مخاطر توسع الحلف نحو حدودهم وانما يلوحون
باجراءات مضاده قد تفتح المشهد اللاهب في
اساسه على كل احتمال
وفي موسكو قال الكرملين ان روسيا تراقب عن
كتب قمه الناتو المنعقده في ليتوانيا
وستتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه بخصوص امن روسيا
وقال المتحدث باسم الكريم
ان انضمام اوكرانيا المحتمل الى الناتو
يشكل خطرا كبيرا على الامن الاوروبي اعتبر
الكريم ان قرار فرنسا رساله صواريخ بعيده
المدى لاوكرانيا خاطئ وستكون له عواقب على
كييف مشيرا الى ان موسكو ستتخذ اجراءات
مضاده واضاف ان انضمام السويد الى الناتو
له تداعيات سلبيه على الامن الروسي
وسيتطلب ردا
ينضم الينا من نافلين عاصمه ليتوانيا جيم
تاوسند نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
السابقه كما ينضم الينا من موسكو السفير
اندريه بكلانوف نائب رئيس جمعيه
الدبلوماسيين الروس ابدا معك سيد اندريس
سيد اندريه الجانب الروسي وعلى اللسان
الكرملين يقول بان ان انضمام السويد يحتاج
او يستوجب ردا كيف سيكون الرد الروسي على
انضمام السويد بعد فنلندا
في الواقع نحن لا نقول هذا فقط بالنسبه
الى ما حصل الان
اعتقد ان احتمال
انضمام
اوكرانيا
لحلف شمال الاطلسيه هي تقريبا صفر هذا
الاحتمال هو تقريبا صفر بالنسبه الى
اوكرانيا هذه النقطه الثانيه وفقا
للمعلومات التي لدينا في روسيا ان حلف
شمال الاطلسي والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اذا حولوا الهدف من العمليه
وابتعدوا عن فكره امكانيه كسب الحرب ضد
روسيا
وهناك احتمال اخر يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار وهو
غير مناسب من قبل
روسيا او بالنسبه الى روسيا الاحتمال الذي
يعمل عليه من قبل حلف شمال الاطلسي هو ان
تكون هذه الحرب حرب طويله
شانها شان الحرب بين العرب واسرائيل معلوم
الموقف
الروسي انضمت والسويد التي من الواضح
بانها ستنضم قريبا عندما يقول الكريم ان
ذلك يهدد الامن الروسي ويستوجب ردا طبيعه
الرد التي يمكن ان تقوم به روسيا
نعم نعم
القياده العسكريه
الروسيه اخذت القرار او اتخذت القرار
ونحن نشكل جيشا جديدا في المناطق الشماليه
من الاتحاد الروسيه والعمل على قدمنا وساق
وهنا ناخذ بعنا الاعتبار الحدود مع فنلندا
بحيث انه ليس لدينا حدود مباشره مع السويد
اذا تعزز القدرات العسكريه الروسيه على
الحدود مع فنلندا بالاضافه الى توجيهي او
التموضع الاسلحه
النوويه في تلك المنطقه بمحاذاه الحدود مع
فنلندا
طيب اتحول الى السيده جيم سيد جيم يعني هل
اعاد حلف شمال الاطلسي الى عقيدته
الاساسيه التي تاسس من اجلها بالقول بان
روسيا تشكل التهديد الاكبر وكيف يمكن ان
تشكل التهديد الاكبر ولكنه حريص على
البقاء على العلاقات معها كيف يمكن تفسير
ذلك
اعتقد ان حلف شمال الاطلسي
لديه بواث قلق حقيقيه وصدمت باجتياح روسيا
لاوكرانيا وجرائم الحرب التي ارتكبت في
اوكرانيا على وجه الخصوص بالنسبه الى قتل
المدنيين وتعذيب المدنيين وبالتالي ان حلف
شمال الاطلسي يتصرف
بالدفاع عن النفس وهو لا يعرف ما اذا كان
الرئيس بوتين سوف يتخذ خطوات باتجاه
استونيا وبولندا او حلفاء اخرين وبالتالي
ان حلف شمال الاطلسي يعزز القدرات
الدفاعيه في الدول المنضويه تحت لواء هذا
التحالف وفي الوقت نفسه يحاول حلف شمال
الاطلسي ان يساعد اوكرانيا كي تساعد نفسها
في مواجهه الاجتياح الروسي اذا ما نراه
الان هو النتيجه طبيعيه لاجتياح روسيا
لاوكرانيا وقرار بوتين الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي ودول العالم طلبت من
بوتين الله يقوم بذلك بعد بروز الادله بان
روسيا تخطط لعمليه مماثله ولكن الرئيس
بوتين تجاهل هذه المطالب ومضى قدما النيتو
ليس لديه اي نيه في الاساس بتعزيز القدرات
لم يكن لديه هذه النيه ولكن الاجتياح
الروسي الذي استهدف اوكرانيا هو الذي غير
المعادله والاولويات بالنسبه الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي سيد
روسيا هي من دفع الناتو الى التوسع من
خلال ما قامت به في اوكرانيا كيف خدمت
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا مصالح روسيا
بابعاد الناتو عن حدودها
في الحقيقه هذه صوره مغلوطه هذا وصف مغلوط
لان العمليه عمليه توسع حلف شمال الاطلسي
بدات بالعام
1982 وذلك عند انضمام الدوله العضو
الجديده انذاك اسبانيا وعبرنا عن احتجاجنا
وبعد ذلك شهدنا خمس موجات من توسع حلف
شمال الاطلسي شرقا للاقتراب من الحدود
الروسيه لذلك قررنا ان نضع حدا لذلك في
ديسمبر من العام 2021
تقدمنا بمقترحا لحلف شمال الاطلسي كي
يتوقف عن سياسه التوسع المستمره بالاقتراب
من الحدود الروسيه نحن طرحنا السبل
الدبلوماسيه بالنسبه الى المساله
الاوكرانيه ولكننا قبلنا بردود سلبيه عند
ذاك اتخذ القرار في روسيا كفى يتعين علينا
ان نواجه هذا التوسع ونحن لن نتوقف حتى
يتوقف النيت عن هذه العمليه شكرا لك سيد
عذرا جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروسيا كنت معنا
من موسكو ويبقى معنا السيد الجيم تاوسند
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه السابق
التباين بشان انضمام اوكرانيا الى الناتو
يعيدنا الى خلافات رصدت منذ بدايه حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا بين كييف وحلفائها في
الغرب خصوصا واشنطن التقرير التالي يضيء
على جانب منها
في اهم اجتماعي للحلفاء والداعمين لبلاده
في حربها ضد روسيا قمه النيتو في ليتوانيا
يظهر الرئيس الاوكراني انزعاجا مما قال
انه عدم تحديد اطار زمني لانضمام اوكرانيا
الى النيتو واصفا ذلك بالامر العبثي وغير
المسبوق كلام منزلنسكي جاء رغم حديث قريب
للرئيس الامريكي يفهم منه عدم نيه الحلف
الذهاب في هذا الاتجاه اذ ربط بايدن
انضمام اوكرانيا للنيتو بانتهاء الحرب كي
لا يكون الحلف مضطرا لخوض مواجهه مباشره
مع روسيا
ما يحدث الان يضاف الى ما يوصف بنقاط
الخلاف او عدم الوفاق بين كييفو واشنطن
فقبل وقت قريب نقلت صحيفه بوليتيكو عن
مسؤولين امريكيين حديثهم عن تباين متزايد
خلف الكواليس بين الولايات المتحده
واوكرانيا قناه الصحيفه النكيه لا تلقي
بالا لنصائح واشنطن العسكريه بشان اهداف
الحرب وكيفيه وموعد نهايتها منها حاله
استنزاف القوات الاوكرانيه لقدراتها في
معركه بخموت شرقا المدينه التي لا تتمتع
باهميه استراتيجيه من وجهه نظر المسؤولين
الامريكيين كذلك الطموح الاوكراني
باستعاده شبه جزيره القرم لم يكن محل
ترحيب امريكي لا بل ان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي شكك في قدره القوات الاوكرانيه
على استعاده شبه الجزيره بعد مرور عقد على
الوجود الروسي فيها استهداف او تخريب خط
نوردسترين للغاز الروسي نحو اوروبا كان
نقطه توتر بين واشنطن
اذ توصل تقييم استخباراتي الى ان مجموعه
مؤيده لاوكرانيا هي من استهدفت خط الغاز
الروسي خليفه العام الماضي
ورغم استمرار حزم المساعدات العسكريه
الامريكيه نحو اوكرانيا تتزايد طلبات كييف
بالحصول على اسلحه متنوعه بشكل مستمر من
صواريخ هايمارس الى منظومه الباتريوت
وصولا الى الدخائر العنقوديه ومقاتلات اف
16 الامر الذي دفع مسؤولين امريكيين الى
ابداء تدمر من حاله الطلب المستمره من
كييف لتلك الاسلحه ومن عدم اظهار الرئيس
الاوكراني اي امتنان مقابل هذا الدعم وفق
حديث وسائل اعلام امريكيه اخيرا اشار
مسؤولون غربيون الى الوضع الداخلي في
اوكرانيا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن تحدث عن ضروره استمرار الاوكرانيين
في اصلاح الجيش وترسيخ الديمقراطيه كما
اشار مسؤولون اخرون الى قضايا فساد وجهت
اصابع الاتهام فيها الى مسؤولين اوكرانيين
رفيعي المستوى منهم وزير الدفاع وحكام
ومقاطعات
نرحب مره جديده بالسيد جمع تاوسند نائب
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق وهو
معنا من ليتوانيا وتنضم الينا الان
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوكراني سيده سلميه مع اوجه الاعتراض
على بيان الناتو خاصه ان هنالك تسهيلات
اعطيت لاوكرانيا وقيل ان مستقبل اوكرانيا
هو في النيتو
في البدايه اود ان اقول
انني انا على المستوى الشخصي وزملائي نشعر
بخيبه امل كبيره وبتوتر كبير ازاءه ما حصل
التزامني مع هذه القمه قمه حلف شمال
الاطلسي والسياسه
المعتمده نحن نتحدث عن سياسه
تعتمد لسنه من الزمن
وتوقعنا ان نستمع الى
قرار
بدعوه لاوكرانيا لكي تنضم الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي وان يعبر حلف شمال الاطلسي عن
نيته
بانضمام اوكرانيا او بضم اوكرانيا الى
التحالف
الاتحاد
متقانياته تم انشاؤه سينعقد في الايام
المقبله ايضا هنالك تسهيلات فيما يتعلق
بملف اليه الانضمام الا يعتبر ذلك تطورا
وخطوه نوعيه في اتجاه انضمام اوكرانيا
لحلف الناتو
يمكنني ان اقول ان هذا هذا الاتفاق حصل
قبل القمه المنعقده حاليا مع الحكومه
الاوكرانيه
وايضا نعود هنا الى سياق الذي يمكن ان
يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار وهو يلحظ التعاون بين
اوكرانيا والدول المنضويه تحت لوائح حلف
شمال الاطلسي والمساعدات المقدمه
لاوكرانيا ولكن مجددا نعود ونقول هذه
القمه تسلط الضوء على السياسه المعتمده من
النيتو مع حلفائنا كندا والولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي وكل الدول لذلك توقعنا
انه بعد كل هذه المرحله التي مضت توقعنا
ان نرى دعوه في مواجهه روسيا
ولاحلال السلام في اوروبا هذا ما توقعناه
من هذه القمه سيد جيم يعني كل هذا الدعم
المقدم لاوكرانيا مساعدات عسكريه مساعدات
انسانيه اسلحه تقدم لاوكرانيا مع ذلك
تعتبر واشنطن بانه لابد من اصلاحات داخل
الجيش الاوكراني اذا على اي اساس تقدم هذه
المساعدات ان لم تكن اوكرانيا ديمقراطيه
كفايه وجيشها يحتاج الى يعني اعاده تاهيل
واصلاح
المساعدات المقدمه الى اوكرانيا من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول الاخرى
هي شامله طبعا لم تصل الى اوكرانيا
بالسرعه المطلوبه ولكنها تركز على الذخيره
والاسلحه النوعيه ما يقترحه حلف شمال
الاطلسي الان هو ضروره تقديم مساعدات
بعيده الامد لاوكرانيا من ضمن حزمه
مساعدات لكي تطمئن اوكرانيا بان المساعدات
سوف تصل اليها في السنوات المقبله بغض
النظر عن الظروف ثانيا هذه الحزمه يجب ان
تتضمن اسلحه نوعيه متقدمه بما في ذلك
الطائرات المقاتله اف 16 ولكن الفكره
الاساسيه هي ان التكنولوجيا يجب ان تكون
مضمنه في هذه الحزم لكي يكون لدى اوكرانيا
الافض على روسيا هذا جزء ايضا من حزم
المساعده وفي الوقت نفسه خلف شمال الاطلسي
كما اشرت شكل هذه هذا المجلس مع مع
اوكرانيا للنظر في هذه الشؤون اذا هذه هي
الامور التي يحاول التحالف ان يقوم بها
لدعم اوكرانيا
واللغه المستخدمه في البيان طبعا انا لا
اتفق مع ما قاله البيان انا اتفق بالفعل
مع زميلتي من كنت اتمنى ان يكون البيان
اشد واقوى ولكن هذا البيان يسلط الضوء على
وجهات النظر مختلفه يعني يمكن ان تكون
الرساله اقوى بكثير لو تم دعوه اوكرانيا
للانضمام الى الحلف من كل هذه المساعدات
التي تقدم لها ما الذي يمنع ذلك فعليا
اعتقد ان الخوف في اوساط الحلفاء والقلق
بان هذه العضويه اذا ما قدمت بشكل مباشر
الى اوكرانيا واخرين بعل الاعتبار الماده
الخامسه في حلف شمال الاطلسين كل ذلك يعني
ان النيتو يكون في حرب مباشره مع روسيا
ولكن هناك وجهات النظر في واشنطن وفي
عواصم اخرى سلطه الضوء على الاصلاحات التي
اشرتم اليها بالنسبه الى الاصلاحات على
المستوى العسكريه وعلى مستوى الحوكمه ولكن
اعتقد ان النيتو يجب ان يكون محددا في
اللغه المستخدمه البيان كان فضفاضا برايه
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق
كنت معنا من فيلينيوس عاصمه ليتوانيا
وايضا الشكر موصول لسولومايا بوبروفيسكا
سكرتيره لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوكراني
قال وزير الدفاع الروسي ان القوات الروسيه
ستضطر الى استخدام الذخائر العنقوديه ضد
القوات الاوكرانيه اذا زودت واشنطن بهذه
الذخائر واشار شويغو الى ان بلاده لم
تستخدم هذا النوع من الاسلحه في اوكرانيا
ادراكا منها للخطر الذي تشكله على حياه
المدنيين وفق قوله
في هذه الاثناء قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
اوليكسي ريزنكوف انه تم تشكيل تحالف يضم
احدى عشره دوله لتدريب القوات الجويه على
طائرات اف 16 من جهتها اعلن السفير
الاوكراني في لندن فديم بريس تايكو ان 20
طيارا اوكرانيا سيبداون التدريب على
الطائرات المقاتله ببريطانيا في نهايه
يوليو او بدايه اغسطس واضاف ان اكثر من 30
الف جندي وضابط اوكراني سيخضعون لتدريبات
عسكريه في بريطانيا هذا العام
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث اعلنت الحكومه رفضها
القاطع لنشر اي قوات اجنبيه في البلاد كما
هاجمت الخرطومه تصريحات الصادره عن الرئيس
الكيني ورئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي خلال قمه
ايجاد معتبره انها تشكل مساسا بسياده
الدوله هذا وقالت السفاره الامريكيه في
الخرطوم ان انتصار اي من الطرفين في
الصراع السوداني ستترتب عليه تكلفه بشريه
غير مقبوله واضافت ان رفض التسويه
التفاوضيه للصراع واستمرار القتال سيكون
امرا غير مسؤول
نرفض نشر اي قوات اجنبيه على ارضنا
وسنعتبرها قوات معتديه هكذا جاء رد
الحكومه السودانيه على البيان الصادر عن
اجتماع اللجنه الرباعيه المنبثقه عن منظمه
الايجاد بشان التطورات في السودان وتضمن
اشاره الى بحث نشر قوات شرق افريقيا
للطوارئ لحمايه المدنيين هناك الرد
السوداني تضمن كذلك استنكارا لتصريحات
الرئيس الكيني ويليامروتو التي دعا فيها
لتشكيل قياده جديده وبشكل عاجل في السودان
واندهاشا من تصريحات رئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبي باحمد بشان وجود فراغ في قياده
الدوله ومطالبته بفرض منطقه حظر طيران
تمهيدا لوقف اطلاق النار معتبرا ان تلك
المواقف تشكل مساسا بسياده الدوله وقد
تدفع السودان لاعاده النظر في جدوى عضويته
في منظمه الايجاد في حين اعتبر مصدرا في
الخارجيه السودانيه التصريحات الكينيه
والاثيوبيه انها مجرد امانيه وتجسيد
لرغبات قوى دوليه وكان وفد الجيش السوداني
قد قاطع اعمال قمه الايجاد بسبب تراوس
كينيا للجلسات اذ يتهموا الجيش نيروبي
بعدم الحياد في الازمه السودانيه
في الاثناء قالت السفاره الامريكيه في
الخرطوم ان انتصار اي من الطرفين في
الصراع القائم في السودان ستكون له كلفه
بشريه باهظه داعيه الاطراف العسكريه الى
ايجاد مخرج تفاوضي من الازمه لتخفيف
الاضرار واضافت السفاره الامريكيه في بيان
لها ان رفض التسويات التفاوضيه للصراع
واستمرار القتال سيكونان امرا غير مسؤول
ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السودانيه الدكتور مزمل
ابو القاسم دكتور مزمل عندما تقول الحكومه
السودانيه بانها ترفض نشر اي قوات اجنبيه
على ارضها وستعتبر هذه القوات معتديه
عمليا كيف هي قادره على الوقوف في وجه نشر
هذه القوات ان اتخذ قرار في ذلك بالطبع لم
يتم اتخاذ قرار في في هذه في هذا الصدر بل
ان
الاجتماعي يفتقر الى
مسمى قمه
لانو ضمه سبع دول كان مفترض ان تشارك
برؤساءها لم يشارك سوى رئيسين اثنين فقط
هما الرئيس الكيني
ورئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي
ابي احمد كان ايضا هنالك حضور امريكي كان
ايضا هنالك حضور بريطاني ممثل من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه يعني كان هنالك الحدود
الدولي لهذه الاليه لاجتماع هذه الاليه
نعم لكن ذلك لا يغير حقيقه ان هذه
الاجتماع لم يفرز اي قرارات بل صدر عنه
بيان وبالتالي لم تكن له مخرجات كانت
عناوين
ومناشدات اكثر من كونها قرارات لم يكن
هناك قرارات كان هناك تلميح وتلويح
باحتمال استخدام قوه قوات اسف التدخل في
السودان ولكن طبعا لم يكون هناك قرار وهذه
بالنسبه
لهذه القوه ايضا لا يتم استخدامها الا
بموافقه الدول نفسها طيب ليس ليس هناك اي
مجال لنشر قوه في دوله موافقتها الرئيس
الحكومه الاثيوبيه والرئيس الكيني بانه
هنالك فراغ على مستوى السلطه هل يمكن ان
يكون يعني يمهد لدخول هذه القوه دون
موافقه الحكومه السودانيه
ليس هناك مجال لادخال هذه القوفيه دوله من
دول الايجاد من دون موافقه الدوله نفسها
او بطلب منها الشيء الثاني السودان احترض
على تفصيل بسيط لديه معااخذ على الرئيس
الكيني
وطلب استبداله برئيس دوله جنوب السودان
على اعتبار ان السودان يرى في ويليام
بروتو
انه غير محايد انه مرتبط بعلاقات اخذ لا
يزال على روتو ام انه ايضا يعني انتقل
وتوسع ليشمل رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي بعد
تصريحاته عن حظر للطيران عن فراغ على
مستوى
القياده والحكومه في السودان هل توسع
الرفض السوداني ليشمل ايضا رئيس وزراء
اثيوبيا
السوداني يعترض ابتداء على رئاسه ويليام
روت ولم يطالب بازاحه كينيا من المبادره
من اللجنه وافق على استمرارها بالرغم من
تحفظاته على عدم حيادها وطلب اسناد
الرئاسه الى رئيس السودان هذا التفصيل كان
يمكن ان تتم مناقشته ويتم اقناع السودان
بالتغاضي عنه او يتم اقناعه الرئيس الكيني
بالتنازل عن الرئاسه اللينه كي تمضي
المبادره قدما
ولكن ذلك لم يحدث وشاهدنا تسرعا كبيرا في
ادانه السودان في اطلاق تصريحات حاده
يعني تكشف حقيقه نوايا الجانبين الكيني
والاثيوبي لا يصح ان يتم تجاوز الغرفه
الدبلوماسي للتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
لدوله
واهانه قيادتها وانكارها مثل ما فعل
الرئيس الكيني ولا يصح للرئيس الوزراء
الاثيوبي عن
يقفز فوق كل الحقائق لو طالب بوقف شامل
لاطلاق النار
كان سيكون حديثه مقبولا ولكنه قفز مباشره
الى حظر الطيران وحذر الاستخدام المدفعيه
يريد ان يجرد الجيش السوداني من ابرز
مناطق انتهى الوقت دكتور مسمى ابو القاسم
الكاتب المحلل السياسي كنت معنا هنا في
الاستديو
[موسيقى]
قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه انه تم
اختطافه اسرائيليا خلال رحله الى اثيوبيا
قبل ايام والخارجيه تتابع الامر وكانت
صحفيه اسرائيليه قد اختطفت في العراق
مؤخرا وحمل رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي كتائب
حزب الله العراقيه مسؤوليه اختطافها
تظاهر الاف اسرائيليين في تل ابيب واغلقوا
طرقا رئيسيه احتجاجا على مشروع قانون
التعديلات القضائيه بعد ان اعتمد الكنيسه
في قراءته الاولى تعديلا قانونيا يقلص
صلاحيات قضاه المحكمه العليا وقال مراسل
الجزيره ان مواجهات وقعت بين متظاهرين
والشرطه دفعت بوحده الخياله وقوات حرس
الحدود لقمع الاحتجاجات بعد ان وصلت الى
مقر المحكمه العليا ياتي ذلك بالتزامن مع
دعوات الى عصيان مدني من رؤساء حكومه
سابقين وقاده اجهزه امنيه لكبح ما سموه
مشروعا لانقلاب على القضاء هذا وطلب البيت
الابيض رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو بالحفاظ على ما وصفه بحق التظاهر
السلمي
[موسيقى]
الصدمات بين الشرطه الاسرائيليه
والمتظاهرين في اكثر من موقع والاعتقالات
بالجمله شكلت ذروه جديده في احتجاجات
شعبيه لا تخبو جذوتها في اسرائيل منذ سته
شهور
[موسيقى]
الشرطه الاسرائيليه حشدت هذه المره قواتها
لقمعها بقوه مفرطه وغير معروضه
يقول هؤلاء انهم يخرجون للدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه في وجه حكومه متطرفه تسعى
للانقلاب على نظام الحكم وتحيد المحكمه
العليا وتقليص صلاحيات قضاتها
[تصفيق]
هنا للدفاع عن دولتنا لن ننكسر ولا نوقف
احتجاجاتنا حتى لو اضطرنا للتظاهر اربع
سنوات متواصله لن نقبل ان تصبح اسرائيل
ديكتاتوريه لذا ندعو الجميع للعوده الى
المفاوضات والتوصل الى تسويه
كل الناس هنا قدموه كل حياتهم من اجل
الدوله من اجل ان تبقى دوله ديمقراطيه
وتبقى دوله قانون وقضاء من اجل المساواه
والحريه لكل المواطنين
اكتست الاحتجاجات زخما بعد تصويت الكنيست
على تعديلات تقيد صلاحيات قضاه المحكمه
العليا في تفعيل رجاحه العقل عند الغاء
قرارات وتعينات للحكومه اذا ما كانت غير
معقوله او مناقضه لقرارات قضائيه
وتترافق الاحتجاجات مع دعوات جنود وضباط
في سلاح الجو ووحدات النخبه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي لاسيان الاوامر العسكريه ان
عصيان الاوامر العسكريه هو اداه للضغط على
الحكومه وثمه اشخاص سيرفضون للخدمه
العسكريه تحت حكومه غير الديمقراطيه في
اساسها
[موسيقى]
وبينما تمضي التوليفه الحاكمه في احداث
التغييرات على الجهاز القضائي تتعالى
اصوات بين رؤساء حكومات وقيادات سياسيه
وعسكريه سابقه في اسرائيل تدعو لاعلان
العصيان المدني وشل مرافق الدوله كافه ولا
يستبعد هؤلاء في تصريحاتهم احتمال انزلاق
اسرائيل الى شفير حرب اهليه هو صراع على
تعديلات قضائيه في ظاهره لكن جوهر الخلاف
هو على شكل اسرائيل بين من يريدها دوله
يمينيه دينيه اصوليه وبين من يقول انها
ينبغي ان تبقى دوله ديمقراطيه علمانيه
متنوره الجزيره
[موسيقى]
الدكتور سليم بريك محاضر في العلوم
السياسيه والخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
دكتور سليم اذا كان ظاهر الخلاف
والتعديلات القضائيه فما هو جوهره والى
اين يمكن ان يصل
مساء الخير التظاهرات اليوم كانت في 120
بؤره وليس فقط في تل ابيب طبعا
المجتمع الاسرائيلي عمليا موجود في ازمه
اجتماعيه وازمه سياسيه ومن هذه الازمه
السياسيه
عمليا دخلنا الى ازمه دستوريه الازمه
الاجتماعيه هي اولا تطور او ازدياد قوه
المستوطنين والصهيونيه الدينيه وجوانب
فاشيه في دوله اسرائيل من ناحيه والحالدين
الذين هم متشددين دينيه من الناحيه الاخرى
هم يريدون تغيير مبنى دوله اسرائيل مبنى
نظام الحكم ومبنى الحياه في دوله اسرائيل
مثل مثلا
زياده في التهويد والى اخره هذا غير مقبول
على غالبيه المجتمع المدني الحكومه الان
تريد اولا تغيير نظام الحكم من اسباب اخرى
ليس فقط داخليه في اسرائيل الا ايضا الحكم
في الضفه الغربيه لانها بحاجه الى اضعاف
سلطه القضاء لكي تستمر في عمليه الاحتلال
كمان في ش
على مستقبل حكومه نتنياهو
باعتقادي انه الامور تتدهور وبسرعه يعني
مثلا كان قبل يومين اجتماع للحكومه هاجموا
فيها المستشاره القضائيه التي عمليا يعني
التغيير القضائي الذي القانون الذي بداوا
به في الليل الماضيه الهدف منه ازاحه
المستشار القضائيه او اقالتها نهائيا
ولكن واضح بان الامور تزداد عمقا اليوم
الشرطه استعملت عنف مفرط مثلا اعتدوا على
احد المغنيين المشهورين على سبيل المثال
الكثير من العنف في اماكن مختلفه انا
بنفسي رايت مشاهد من هذا القبيل طبعا هذا
واضح لان بنج فير يضغط على الشرطه لكي
تتعامل بشكل عنيف مع المتظاهرين هؤلاء
المتظاهرين هم في باقي الوقت ضباط في
الجيش او جنود في الجيش في الاحتياط وهاهم
الان يدفعون ثمن دفاعهم عن ما يرونه كنظام
ديموقراطي ليبرالي ولذلك الشخص سيتعمق الى
ان يتخذ نتنياهو قرار نهائي اما هو يختار
البيت الابيض وعالم الغربي الاوروبي واما
ان يختار سمبطرش وبنجفير والقوى الفاشيه
التي ركبها حكومته على اساسها اضافه الى
الحالتين طبعا شكرا لك دكتور سليم بريك
محاضر في العلوم السياسيه والخبيره في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه
نعود الى قضيه القدس التي
تناولناها في فقره قبل الحصاد حيث اقتحمت
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منزل عائله صب
لبن المطل مباشره على المسجد الاقصى
بالبلده القديمه مراسلتنا جيفارا البديري
رصدت المشهد على الارض
مع ساعات الفجر الاولى
قوات كبيره من جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اقتحموا منزل العائله فقط سال على عجاله
السيده نوره صباح الخير السيد صباح النور
خالتي شو اللي صار الصبح اخذوا البيت يا
خالتي استولى على البيت بالقوه الجيش
والشرطه والمستوطنين اخذوا البيت مني بيت
اللي عايشه فيه بيت المولوده فيه بيت اللي
يتمس فيه من الام والاب بيت اخوتي فيه كل
بيتي كله ذكريات لازم كل هدول يعرفوا لوك
اسرائيل تيك ماي هاوس
ديس نورا تخاطب العشرات من المتضامنين
الاسرائيليين والاجانب الذين نراهم هنا
عبر عدسه الكاميرا ويتواجدون هنا في
المحيط بالطبع فقط ان سمح لي مجيد سنشير
الى
[موسيقى]
مع انتهاء عاصفه الاحتجاجات على مقتل
الشاب نائل على يد شرطي فرنسيا في احدى
ضواحي باريس بدات الحكومه في تقييم حجم
الخسائر التي طالت الاقتصاد الفرنسي ووفق
تقديرات فان التكلفه تصل الى اكثر من
مليار يورو من ضمن هذه الفاتوره 650 مليار
يورو ستدفعها شركات التامين فاتوره
الاحتجاجات الاخيره وفق التقديرات تتجاوز
تكلفه احتجاجات عام 2005
مرات قطاع السياحه تضرر بشكل كبير خلال
هذه الموجه حيث الغيت رحلات جويه وحجوزات
خاصه من السياح الاجانب ووصلت نسبه
الالغاء الى اكثر من 25% وفي بعض المدن
الى خمسين في المئه ففي حين حقق قطاع
السياحه خلال نفس الفتره من العام الماضي
عائدات تجاوزت خمسه مليارات يورو من غير
المقيمين يتوقع الخبراء ان القطاع قد يشهد
عجزا يبلغ نحو مليار يورو هذا العام هذا
وتحتل فرنسا المرتبه السابعه في قائمه
الاقتصادات العالميه والثالثه بين الاسواق
الاوروبيه يعتمد اقتصادها بشكل اساسي على
قطاعات الاغذيه الزراعيه والمصارف
والتامين وصناعه السيارات ايضا كما تعتبر
فرنسا الطاقه النوويه جزءا هاما من
استراتيجيتها لتوفير الطاقه فيما يمثل
القطاع السياحي نسبه 8% من مجمل اقتصادها
قبل الحصاد التقيت اوليفيا الوزير المنتدى
بلا وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه المكلف
بالتجاره الخارجيه والجاذبيه الاقتصاديه
والفرنسيين المقيمين في الخارج وخل ال
اللقاء سالته عن زيارته للعاصمه القطريه
الدوحه وعن اقتصاد الفرنسي ومدى تاثره
بالاحتجاجات الاخيره
من الزياره الى دوله قطر هدفهم بسيط من
جهتين بصفه وزيره التجاره الخارجيه
والجاذبيه انا اتيت من اجل تعزيز هذا
الاواصر الاقتصاديه القويه والماتينه بين
فرنسا ودوله قطر في مجال الطاقه وكذلك في
مجال النقل وكذلك
للتحضير للاستثمارات المباشره في مجله
اقتصاديه اخرى انا ايضا الوزير المسؤول عن
الفرنسيين المقيمين في الخارج وجئت التقي
بالمقيم الفرنسيين في دوله قطر لدينا 120
شركه متواجده وعامله في دوله قطر اتحدث عن
شركه فرنسيه انهم مغتربون مقيمون في
الخارج يعملون في هذا الشركات وبالتالي
استفيد للقاء هؤلاء الفرنسيين هنالك غايات
متعدده من هذه الزياره اذا
للدوحه منها التبادل التجاري الميزان
التجاري سجل انهيارا وعجز ا كبيرين العامه
تجاوز 164 مليار يورو جهودكم مع شركاء
الخارجيين الى اين وصلت
بالنسبه الى عجز الميزان التجاري الفرنسي
ال 164 مليار الذي نتحدث عنه هي طبعا
استثنائيه من حيث حجمها لان السنه الماضيه
كان لدينا هذه الازمه ازمه الطاقه التي
مردها حرب روسيا العدائيه ضد اوكرانيا
وهذا يرتبط بان فرنسا كانت قد اوقفت
منشاتها النوويه وجب عليها ان تعوض عن
سنتي عدم عمل هذه المنشات خلال جائحه
كورونا ووجب علينا استيراد الطاقه اكثر من
العاده وهذه الطاقه كلفتها ثلاثه اضعاف
وكذلك اليورو فقد من قيمه مقارنه بالدولار
في السوق ايضا لدينا عجز هيكلي يقارب 80
مليارا
ونحن في صدد معالجته من خلال اطلاق ثوره
صناعيه في فرنسا ومن خلال دعم الشركات
التي تصدر الى الخارج وصفت هذا العجز
بالاستثنائي بسبب ما يجري من حرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا وازمه الطاقه بعد اكثر من
عام على هذه الحرب هل وجدت فرنسا الحل
الامثل فيما يتعلق بازمه الطاقه والاعتماد
على الغاز الروسي
ان جزء من الحل او من الجواب ياتي من دوله
قطر بفضل العلاقات التي تربطنا بقطر
نستورد من دوله قطر الغاز الطبيعيه الموصل
الذي يتيح لنا بسد حاجاتنا في مجال الطاقه
في الوقت نفسه قعدنا تشغيل منشاتنا
النوويه لانتاج الكهرباء من اجل سد
الحاجات
فيما يتعلق بصوره فرنسا بعد الاحداث
الاخيره التي شهدتها هل تخشون على صوره
فرنسا بعد ما شهدناه من عنف والاحداث في
الضواحي
سوف لن اكون صادقا اذا قلت ان هذه الصور
تعزز جاذبيه فرنسا ولكن اريد ان اتحدث عن
هذه الاحداث ما هي القصه حصلت ماساه بعد
توقيف شاب لم يكن يحترم اوامر الشرطه
بالتوقف وللاسف هذا الشاب توفي خلال عمليه
التوقيف طبعا هي ماساه ادت الى انفعالات
مشروعه طبعا
بالمقابل وخلف هذه الانفعالات حصلت اعمال
عنف هي غير مقبوله وهي التي شكلت اساس
اوامر صدرت من اجل التوقيف عدد من الاشخاص
ارتكبوا العنف سيحاولون الى القضاء واليوم
اعيد النظام وستب الامن ونحن نعالج هذه
المشكله التي هي منتشره بين الشباب الرئيس
ماكرون قد
بسياسه لتحرير هؤلاء الشبان والشابات
وتوفير فرص متكافئه لهم حتى يجدوا مكانتهم
في المجتمع الفرنسي وما اقوله بالنسبه الى
الجاذبيه لا يجب ان نخلط بين تظاهرات
استمرت خمسه ايام
والاسس اسس هذه الجاذبيه الفرنسيه فرنسا
اليوم هي اول دوله في اوروبا من حيث
الجاذبيه تسبق المانيا والمملكه المتحده
لقد استقبلنا السنه الماضيه اكثر من 125
مشروعا استثماريا اجنبيا ونقدم عددا كبيرا
من فرص العمل وهذه الاسس متينه الاقتصاد
ايجابي ونمو ايجابي لدينا اكثر معدل تضخم
متدني في الاتحاد الاوروبي
وحققنا ذلك من خلال تخفيض الضرائب على
الانتاج والشركات وعززنا مرونه سوق العمل
وكنا نتحدث موضوع الطاقه النوويه نريد ان
نخفض سعر الطاقه اكثر من دول اخرى
وكذلك تدريب الكوادر والمهارات والكفاءات
من اجل الشركات هذه هي الاسس التي نعتمد
عليها لتعزيز هذه الجاذبيه الفرنسيه يوما
بعد يوم وهي فعلا المؤشرات الحاسمه
للمستثمرين اصحاب الشركات والمشاريع حين
يقررون الاستثمار في فرنسا يحسبون هذه
المؤشرات ولا يعتمدون على بعض الصور التي
مرت على القنوات التلفزيونيه والتي تعكس
الوضع فقط لمده ايام قليله نحن لا نتحدث
عن خمسه ايام فقط نحن نتحدث عن مواجهات
تتكرر في فرنسا منذ سنوات طويله لماذا لم
تستطع فرنسا حل جذور الازمه وكيف يمكن ان
يؤثر ذلك على صوره فرنسا بشكل عام
مره اخرى نحن لا نتحدث عن مواجهات في
فرنسا على مر ايام السنه نتحدث عن بعض
الظواهر
وعشناها نعم صحيح في 2005 وعشناها خمسه
ايام هذا العام هناك اعمال عنف ترتكبها
عصابات للاسف في بعض الاحياء
وهذا للاسف منتشر في مدن اوروبيه اخرى في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اذا هذا ليست
مشكله محصوره بفرنسا نتحدث عن مشكله
وللاسف تطال الكثير من الدول الاوروبيه
وفي امريكا الشماليه هي مشكله نسعى الى
معالجتها من اجل دمج افضل
للشباب في مجتمعاتنا وكذلك
مكافحه والتصدي للمافيات لهذا الاقتصاد
الجانبي الذي يتغلغل في احيائنا فيما
تتحدث سيد اوليفيا عن العصابات ودور
العصابات لكن لجنه القضاء على التمييز
العرقي التابعه للامم المتحده تتحدث عن
ممارسات التنميط العنصري والاستخدام
المفرط للقوه في انفاذ القانون اذا
المسؤوليه لا تقع فقط على من سميتهم
بالعصابات هنالك مسؤوليه تقع على مؤسسات
الدوله الا تعتقد ذلك
تذكرونه بالنسبه الى الامم المتحده
نحن نتحدث هنا عن مجرد لجنه داخل الامم
المتحده بالنسبه للجنه حقوق الانسان تستند
الى ظاهره او ظاهرهتين لنكون واضحين هنا
ليس لان دوله مات تعاني بعض من هذه
الظواهر
الخاطئه داخل مؤسسه الشرطيه يمكن ان نتهم
الشرطه بالتمييز العنصري او بالعنف
خطا خطاان حادثه حادثتان لا يجب ان يلغيا
هذه الممارسات او
الاخلاقيات التي تعتمدها الشرطه لا احد
فوق القانون بعض الشرطيين يمارسون العنف
في ممارساتهم ويتخطون القانون يخترقون
القانون يرتكبون التمييز العنصر حينذاك
يحاولون الى القضاء ويدانون نحن نتحدث عن
دوله قانون وهذا ما علينا ان نقوم به ان
نجعل القانون محترما شكرا لك
الوزير المنتدى بلدى وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه المكلف بالتجاره الخارجيه
والجاذبيه الاقتصاديه والفرنسيين المقيمين
في الخارج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عليه السلام
[موسيقى]
الله
اكبر
[موسيقى]
28 عاما والجرح لم يندمل كما شاهدنا في
الصور في البوسنه حضر الاف الاشخاص مراسم
دفن رفات 30 من ضحايا الاباده في سرب
نيتسيا اباده قتل فيها اكثر من ثمانيه
الاف وثلا من مسلمين البوسنه على يد عناصر
من جيش صرب البوسنه ماساه لن تنسى صدمت
العالم حينها وما زالت جرحا مؤلما بالنسبه
للناس هناك نهايه الحصاد تصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]